[Music]
the question of whether jesus had a wife
has long been the subject of mystery and
speculation
what if jesus was married to mary
magdalene what if they have descendants
that live amongst us
this idea forms the basis of the da
vinci code and continues to enrapture
the public imagination but it's not just
the realm of fiction or conspiracy you
see there's an ancient christian text
that seems to confirm this theory it's a
tiny fragment of papyrus with an
astonishing revelation that jesus had a
wife
the so-called gospel of jesus's wife
sent shockwaves throughout biblical
scholarship it had the potential to
rewrite everything we knew about the
life of jesus
but it didn't
why
what happened to this text
it's a long story
[Music]
measuring about the size of a credit
card the gospel of jesus's wife is a
tiny fragment of papyrus it was
presumably part of a much larger
document
but this is all that remains
the writing is in coptic an egyptian
language that was once widely spoken in
antiquity
translating the text reveals a
conversation between jesus and his
disciples it's a little hard to make out
but there's one part that's crystal
clear on line 4 right in the center it
reads
jesus said to them
my wife
could this prove that jesus was actually
married
when this text was revealed to the
public in 2012 the identity of this
mystery wife was clear
mary magdalene mary magdalene is a
character from the new testament not to
be confused with jesus's mother who's
also called mary
no this mary was one of jesus most
trusted followers and was present at his
crucifixion and burial she's most famous
for being the first to witness jesus
after his resurrection
however nowhere does it say that she was
his wife in fact the new testament has
zero references to jesus's marital
status because of this many safely
assumed that he was celibate
the idea that jesus and mary had a
secret relationship is a popular one
most famously explored in the da vinci
code the best-selling novel by dan brown
the success of this book and subsequent
film sparked all kinds of wild
conspiracies with some people even
claiming to be their direct descendants
blockbusters and conspiracies aside
jesus having a wife is actually a rather
ancient idea it has its roots in gnostic
christianity a collection of christian
sets that flourished from the first
century onwards particularly in egypt
gnostics believed that they had access
to hidden esoteric knowledge about jesus
primarily contained in their sacred
texts they produced their own gospels
and teachings mainly about the special
status of mary magdalene one such text
is the so-called gospel of mary in one
passage peter tells mary that quote
sister we know that the savior loved you
more than all other women
similarly the gospel of philip describes
her as jesus's companion and that is
meant to have quote
loved her more than all the disciples
and
kissed her often on the mouth
the gospel of jesus's wife was
supposedly one of these gnostic texts
but is the only one that explicitly
states that jesus had a wife it seems to
complete that puzzle surrounding mary
magdalene and that they were married
making the da vinci code appear more
like historical fact than historical
fiction
these gnostic texts make some startling
claims but it's important to note that
these were pretty fringe beliefs even
for the time many of these gnostic
gospels were written centuries after
jesus's death meaning that they probably
were not eyewitness accounts the gospel
of jesus's wife was said to have been
written around the 4th century a.d so
pretty late for a christian text of this
nature compare this with the new
testament books the canonical gospels
were written around ad70 to ad110 just
enough to be an eyewitness account and
why they're considered to be more
authoritative
then again maybe the gospel of jesus's
wife is a copy of a much older version
perhaps an original that has since gone
missing with this being the last
surviving copy if so it would offer a
precious glimpse into jesus's largely
unknown personal life
at the time the gospel of jesus's wife
was an electrifying discovery such a
startling revelation had the potential
to rewrite everything people knew about
jesus jesus's celibacy is often used as
a reason why some priests can't get
married if jesus did in fact have a wife
then those ancient rules would have to
be rewritten
then there's the big picture stuff
theologically speaking jesus is believed
to have been god incarnate what would it
mean if god fell in love with a mortal
woman
too many questions
and it's not just jesus's biography we'd
have to change but also that of mary
magdalene being jesus's significant
other would raise her status
considerably the figure of mary
magdalene is already a complicated one
whenever she is named in the new
testament she is depicted quite
positively and as a key member of
jesus's inner circle but from about the
second century onwards early christian
writers began to conflate her with other
women like the unnamed prostitute or the
sinful adulteress that jesus meets
elsewhere in doing so they forever
tarnished the interpretation of this
character
if it turned out that she was the wife
of jesus these traditional beliefs would
have to be challenged the gospel of
jesus's wife is a remarkable document
jesus being married would transform a
lot of beliefs
if it was genuine of course
and that's where things get a little
complicated
as soon as it was revealed to the public
tv documentaries were being prepared
about this unusual find there was
already plenty of public interest
especially as the da vinci code had been
such a big hit but there were those who
are less caught up with the media frenzy
and cast doubts over the authenticity of
this document
forged manuscripts have long been a
problem for biblical scholars because
they are so exceptionally rare museums
and universities are willing to pay
enormous sums for them especially if
they contain astonishing information
like ours but there are also those who
can create convincing fakes and sell
them off as genuine
every year one or two fragments are
discovered to be forged to an untrained
eye it's pretty hard to tell but
biblical scholars have become very good
at it with the gospel of jesus wife
experts found a number of telltale signs
that forgery was afoot the handwriting
was unusual consisting of thick clumsy
letters uncharacteristic for these kinds
of artifacts what's more almost all of
the texts had been lifted from another
book the gospel of thomas
the only detail that's been changed is
the wife bit how convenient the copywork
is shoddy there are several spelling
mistakes and grammatical errors
something was very wrong
all the signs pointed to forgery
rumors about the document began to grow
and soon shrouded it in speculation the
documentaries and tv specials were put
on hold until further notice eventually
the fragment was taken to be carbon
dated a process which can accurately
determine the age of the material to the
surprise of many the test indicated that
the papyrus was indeed ancient it dates
to around the 8th century a.d admittedly
it's a few centuries off the original
time frame but is still very old
so surely that's case closed right does
this mean that it's a genuine gnostic
text
not quite you see you can fool a carbon
dating test all you need are empty
fragments of old parchment on which to
add text to later on you'd be surprised
by how many blank scraps turn up on the
black market
with our document the papyrus itself is
ancient but the writing was added at a
later date the modern inks used suggest
that it came from not the 8th century
but from the 21st century
there were still those who desperately
clung onto the idea that the gospel of
jesus's wife was real but it was growing
more and more obvious it wasn't it was a
fake and to be honest not a very good
one it was a dubious forgery designed to
cash in on the success of the da vinci
code preying on the public hope that
jesus might have had a wife the scandal
damaged reputations and ruined careers
scholars put their reputation on the
line and some lost it all but once the
dust settled and the clamour died down
one piece of the puzzle remained
unaccounted for
who was the mystery forger a report from
the atlantic traced it back to walter
fritz a german immigrant who was living
in florida fritz was the ideal candidate
for hoax of this kind he was a student
of egyptian languages like coptic who
was expelled from his university for
plagiarism
when asked whether he was the hoaxer he
denied it although he did admit that he
quote might have been able to do so had
he tried
had it been real the gospel of jesus's
wife would have been a miraculous
discovery to many it would have been
proved that jesus was indeed married but
as time went on the text was quickly
determined to be a hoax on inspection
nothing about it seemed genuine from the
clumsy handwriting to the grammatical
errors
i suspect the newsfeed being a fake
would have come as a great
disappointment many were hoping that it
would either shine a light into gnostic
christianity or simply prove that dan
brown was onto something
jesus was famous for his parables and so
the warning of this tale is for those
who get swept up by media frenzy and
conspiracy theories even though this
document was ultimately fraudulent it
was a catalyst for some interesting
conversations for example how much do we
really know about the life of jesus all
we have are texts from the new testament
and a few other sources but they only
really cover the final few years of his
life ultimately we know very little
about jesus as a historical figure so
for now the mystery of whether he had a
wife is ongoing we'll have to wait and
see if another ancient fragment pops up
but next time we'll hopefully be more
careful
hey thanks for watching had a great time
making this and i hope you enjoyed it as
well if you like this video and want to
see more why not subscribe a like and a
comment also go a really long way oh and
do check out the channel's merch over at
crowdmade we have beanies t-shirts and
hoodies links are in the description
down below
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye